as we've been telling you doctors say
getting a flu shot is more important
than ever during this pandemic
and that's especially true for people
who are over 65 because they're at high
risk for serious complications
from both viruses health experts
recommend what's called a high-dose
flu vaccine which has four times more
antigen than the regular shot
age our bodies have a bit more
difficulty making that antibody response
to a regular dose vaccine so if we
expose people who are over the age of 65
to a higher dose of that antigen they're
more likely to make a much more robust
response
some pharmacies and doctors are
reporting limited supplies of the high
dose vaccine or that it's even no longer
in stock
but doctors say older adults should not
delay and take whatever shot is
available
meantime health district is hosting the
last of its no-cost
flu vaccine clinics next week it's going
to be over
at silverado high school the address is
right there on your screen on silverhawk
it's going to run from one to five in
the middle of the day the flu shot will
be available for both adults and
children
six months of age and older and they
will be given on a first come first
serve basis again it's free
and no appointments are necessary